today we're driving an ambitious luxury
sedan the Audi v8 its most important
components four-wheel drive eight
cylinders and zero headaches thanks to
its automatic transmission in 1988 howdy
CEO Ferdinand pshhh ventured into the
luxury league with the v8 back then
luxury was strictly the domain the
mercedes-benz s-class and the BMW
7-series
dowdy for us as our test driver
christophe recalls when ferdinand pshh
was allowed to present his newest baby
zack then he said the Audi v8 was sure
to stir up the entire luxury class so
expectations were high and the press
couldn't stop speculating about his name
howdy 300 harsh first the premium brands
found not a chance Howdy's new luxury
model was simply referred to by its
initials v8 was bad enough much worse
was that this new top-of-the-line model
was the spitting image of Audis
mid-range cars 100 and 200 which both
lived outdated and exciting the Austin
but despite similarities in design v8
technology is far superior to its
middle-class cousins can only agree that
the car feels incredibly athletic and
dynamic cornering is excellent he says
and you'd have to work hard to drive it
off track despite its many technical
innovations it stand a whole slew of
endurance tests without even the
slightest misfire setup which is great
considering that even back then
individual replacement parts were
astronomical find a new motor for
example cost twenty thousand marks
that's as much as a brand new golf
when it comes to performance the v8
engines 3.6 litre capacity and 250
horsepower weren't initially convincing
it wasn't until 1991 that it's 280
horsepower 4.2 liter motor brought the
car's performance back on par with
expectations on automatic the v8 powers
from 0 to 100 in under 8 seconds and
reaches a top speed of 249 more hands-on
people can reach 100 in less than 7
seconds in any weather and on any
surface for the cleverly designed
four-wheel-drive distributes power to
the wheels with the most traction
ideally that means the power is
distributed evenly between the front and
the back axles but in extreme cases it
can sense 100% just one to demonstrate
the four-wheel drive superiority they
sent a v8 straight to own racetrack hide
the kepada one clip Schmitt becomed
shake mundane for a quarter hunt of
defense liquor 1990 hands you out him
stuck one the German Touring Car
Championship
1991 is team colleague Frank Baylor
triumphed the drivers done their v8
Quattro DTM with 420 PS the chauffeurs
limousine and even competitors were
joking about the taxi in the end the
audi pilots had the last laugh when the
Audi v8 came into the market in 1988
there was only one equipment variant and
it had a catch with automatic
transmission air conditioning and
leather and Walmart interior it was
almost 30 percent more expensive than
the competitors BMW and Mercedes basic
models but it has four-wheel drive so
you can even drive it through a Sanford
like this the competition couldn't snap
but who pays a hundred thousand marks
for a car that looks like an overweight
OD 100 being understated is not a
winning argument when it comes to luxury
serious business could cut all the
similarity is no coincidence either
the fully galvanized v8 inherited its
floor assembly in central section from
the 100 model yet it's bulky rear newly
designed front and flared fenders
weren't enough to distinguish it from
middle-class models
[Music]
what were though were technical treats
like the 4 position memory seat function
and its safety system pro/con 10 in a
head-on collision it tightens the seat
belts and pulls the steering column away
from the driver making the Audi v8 one
of the safest cars of its class our test
driver points out another highlight
that's hidden directly in the name v8
the fully redesigned 8 cylinder engine
complete with 32 valves and 4 overhead
camshafts made entirely of aluminium
it's particularly durable and can easily
last 400,000 kilometers with the proper
care however there were only a few
mechanics who really understood this
complex technology so now he's found it
specialised v8 support bases there and
only there is the brand's flagship truly
in good hands shifter marketing versus
Gordon
[Music]
the fire dynamic that first off was
impressed by the driving dynamics and
says the best place to sit in a v8 is
behind the wheel this is a fun car not
one to be chauffeured in and only one
percent of the buyers chose the more
expensive long version but that wasn't
the only reason sales figures lagged
behind expectations Maori struggled to
find new customers presenting a cheaper
basic model and launching a huge
marketing campaign with packages
guaranteed mobility the works
meanwhile the competitors were joking
Aldi would soon start shining customers
shoes just to get them into their car
the concordance DiMartino think on that
yeah Denis threatenin cannot assure the
puts them attendees outdoor ends day in
the six years it was manufactured only
21,000 well-to-do customers chose the
Audi v8 initial planning had calculated
14,000 models a year the alternative in
the luxury class found only exceptional
buyers
as financial stuff agrees the VA
certainly wasn't a financial success did
set the trend for four-wheel-drive in
upper class model cells and the driving
dynamics safety were enough to convince
even the stoutest skeptics the first
upper class Aldi and the first luxury
sedan with four-wheel drive the Audi v8
was definitely a milestone in car
history and my automobile ashita the
succeeding a8 finally managed the
anticipated breakthrough it firmly
positioned audi in the luxury car class
and even became a state car